my name is Guillermo Kristen those a
good attempt by say my name
I am the CTO of antenna skew to complete
that tries to help clients understand
their customers better
by analyzing activity data which is why
we did this kind of work and I've called
I've given this a subtitle an
unprincipled approach because what I
hope to get and the balance of this talk
is an idea of how we went through the
application of autoencoders so with this
talk will cover some deep learning of a
really neural network prerequisites just
so that we're all on the same page
our motivating problem why we did any of
this work auto-encoders of course and
then a brief discussion about sparsity
and loss functions and finally future
work what this talk will not cover is
complex mathematics optimization and
detail though you should have a strong
intuition about why neural networks
learn and generative models in detail
though hopefully we do get to have a
discussion towards the end about that so
to begin with we usually start with with
this if you're looking at a single layer
neural network this is the traditional
notation for it you'll have some linear
transform of X plus a bias that'll
produce a value Z and you'll take that
and pass it through some activation
function usually some nonlinear
activation function and that'll give you
H and a different representation for
this often uses this right that's the
the neural in neural networks the
analogy to biology and it's just an
explanation of how you take a particular
input and multiply it by a particular
row and a weight matrix sum all of that
up add the bias and again pass it
through a function and I usually find it
useful to have visual representations of
what I'm doing understanding visually
the work that I'm doing and you can
think of that weight matrix just as a
just the matrix instead of numbers
hopefully close to zero random depending
on the problem that you're trying to
solve and your training set or your
batch as I said of column vectors that
if you dot product you'll get some set
of scalar values which you want to pass
through those linear activations at
nonlinear activations and in Python is
straightforward right just to NP dot
take a weight matrix your samples and
add that bias
and finally just pass it through that
function right a rectified linear unit
or a hyperbolic tangent or a Sigma it so
squishing the value usually or
constraining it in some way in the case
of a linear activation and I've always
found it useful to think of each row in
that weight matrix sort of as a template
so in the linear case each row ends up
being a template on how to deal with the
different dimensions of your input and
if I was thinking about doing this in MX
net which is part of what this talk is
about I would do it in the following way
just import the MX netlibrary
define a variable for my input to find a
variable for my weights define a
variable for my bias do the dot product
do the addition and then pass it through
an activation function MX and that
provides a bunch of different api's and
I'm going to be using the symbolic API
but you can see how here were
essentially sort of building a symbolic
graph a graph of computation and I've
added this little bit at the end you can
create an executor using a simple bind
mechanic and the context I'll talk about
the context later but that executor is
quite useful because we've before you've
done anything you haven't executed any
programs you're just building your
architecture you can start introspecting
that architecture do the shapes match
are you are you doing things the way
that you're supposed to do when you do
or do do your dimensions work and that's
pretty useful so that you avoid time
later fixing problems a different way to
do this slightly shorter simpler way to
do this is choosing the fully connected
layer and the pulley connected layer is
sort of like the dense layer and other
frameworks and you just have to pass the
number of hidden units that you'd like
to the fully connected layer and then
back on to that activation so so far so
good it should be basic basic general
our stuff great all of this really is to
say if this was a single layer neural
network your prediction Y hat would be
given by primarily your W right most of
your model is in that W though of course
there's a bias and it does go through a
nonlinear transform but why does that
matter well in the context of neural
networks really in the context of any
optimization problem you're trying to
find the difference between what you
predicted and what was true
whether that's an unsupervised and
you're comparing the same thing or in
the supervised setting and that's with
respect to your
right so you have some cost function J
with respect to to W and to B and you
want to find which WS and B's meet the
criteria or find the solution right and
really that's just the process of moving
the values in W and the values in B so
that you get to to the point that you're
interested in and that's really just
traversing the surface of a loss
function there's a great talk yesterday
about a day before yesterday about
following the gradient the this should
tell you a lot is you give you an
intuition about the importance of your
loss function right so it has to be of
course differentiable but its surface
will determine how easy it is to
actually end up solving your your
problem and usually will solve it with
some version of stochastic gradient
descent some subset of steps that we
take in fact here the jagged lines
represent the fact that we're using
batches and not the full data set and so
we sort of oscillate through this
through the surface until we find a
solution if we converge of course some
thing that I've found useful in the past
too is to think about what you're doing
imagine that you're the function that
you're trying to solve is just explicit
and in most frameworks that explicit
function ends up being a computation
graph and that's just a very simple
computation graph you have in this case
w1 times w2 plus B and you can imagine
how that computation graph ends up
acquiring some values that you propagate
forward why does that matter well I
found this useful intuition because you
can easily see from description like
this one how back propagation would work
right so if you wanted to find the the
partial derivative of each of these
interim steps it's this sort of the
intuition of the chain rule where you
just go back one step and go back one
step and go back one step ok so our
problem why why are we looking
autoencoders now they have a little bit
of background on one that works we're
looking at auto-encoders because of the
data that we handle in particular
because it's a very sparse very large
data set and in particular we're looking
at a very highly dimensional space so
our vocabulary is millions of potential
actions it's even though it's a very
large data set
as in we get millions and millions of
samples it is very sparse and also very
variable so the mean number of actions
that a customer that we're analyzing
takes to a customer that we're not using
on behalf of a client per week is 4.1
and the mean number of actions per day
is 1.8 so what does that mean there's a
bunch of problems one we're dealing with
that amount of data millions of records
in this very high dimensional space
there's also a number of problems in
trying to figure out how to get the the
meaningful structure from that data of
course there's also the problem of this
being discrete data these are accounts
of action types think of an action type
as maybe somebody visited a support
website or got a certain support SMS
right that's an action type and I count
the number of times that those happen
those exist in a discrete space there's
also multiple downstream modeling tasks
that we'd like to be able to do after we
process this data in the context of
telecoms and often other industries that
have this type of this form of data you
won't use behavioral data almost at all
because it's so unwieldy and when you do
use it you use it in very specific cases
so you take your 8 million plus
vocabulary and you interview you look at
a single action type because you care
about that you can't do that over and
over again especially if you have
constraints and time and resources for
each iteration there's a there's a big
engineering problem there and we're
trying to solve a little bit of that but
there's also of course a data science
problem there so what do we want we want
to transformation from a discrete space
to a continuous space we'd like a
representation that is smaller and
easier to use
just from a data engineering perspective
it's easier to handle less subject to
memory constraints we'd also like to
make sure that we find that embedding so
that representation has properties that
are useful in downstream modeling tasks
that's a pretty key part so we must
retain the information while also
keeping within the representation the
characteristics that will be useful
later and in particular for our case
we'd like to make sure that that
representation keeps characteristics
that are useful in modeling sequences so
you can think of a piece of data as a
time unit a day
a month and in a way you can think of it
say as this you get a particular
customer service domain accessed or a
particular SMS sent and we'll take that
piece of data very sparse count and
we'll start modeling over it
and each of these will look at this
visual representation later each of
these will be what will attempt to
compress these so that we can use them
later and of course we didn't go for our
own quarters first any data signs
problem that you have go for the
simplest version first and then try the
next thing and the first thing that we
tried of course was matrix factorization
we tried a bunch of different types of
matrix factorization and we ended up
arriving at the conclusion that we were
able to compress the space in a
meaningful way right we were able to
find some principal factors if you will
the reconstruction our ability to
compress that space was really limited
by the the ability to keep rare
information so in the end if we chose a
large number of factors in our
compression then it was almost linear
the the benefit that we got on rare
domains to be much clearer
it was the same if we just kept the most
popular domains by count and didn't do
any most popular domains with popular
actions and didn't do any compression
this is important because rare actions
are often the ones that you care about
and this is past removing things are
very popular and normalizing so if I
take an idea of auto-encoders what we're
trying to do is find that embedding and
we can start with this definition so you
have some function that takes some input
X and gives you an encoding and then
some function that takes that encoding
and gives you a deconstructed version of
X right and so the loss would be X
itself and G of f of X right and a
simpler way to think about this is you
have some data set you're finding you're
trying to find this the small in
representation that's able to reproduce
the data set with the best fidelity if
you will in this case we're talking
about an under complete auto encoder and
then under complete auto encoder is just
one where this the the bottleneck the
space that you're trying to compress
through is smaller than the original
input dimensions
and you can have over complete
auto-encoders where the where the
bottleneck in fact isn't a bottleneck
right it's an expansion and over
complete auto-encoders just on their own
make no sense but you you can do some
things to make sure that the over
complete representation gives you useful
properties for example adding noise and
you some of you might have looked at
denoising auto-encoders in that context
this can be used for you know things
that you've probably seen in the web
reconstructing images or reconstructing
sound waves or also reconstructing
certain types of discrete data like the
one that we're doing there and an
intuition for it there's a simple
intuition for this is if I ask you to do
that
advise you to remember that sentence and
just choose two words to remember it
you'd probably think of something like
blue and sentence or I don't know what
you choose but that's the idea you're
compressing the space right you only
have two words slightly more in detail
that encoded representation if you go
back to the original neural network
description that we gave right the
single layer it's almost the same right
so we have some weights one x x+ the
bias that gives you the encoder and then
the decoder you can have tied weights in
the case of tied weights each layer
essentially shares the weight matrix in
that case w2 would end up being really
just the transpose of w1 and that's
useful in certain scenarios where you
want to force constraints we are not
using tight weights and we don't need to
apply that constraint but if I was
looking at the sin MX that because
that's part of what I would hopefully
like you to get out of the talk it would
sort of look like this I have some set
of layers that I'm defining and by
layers I mean the input dimensions of
each layer and then some method that
builds a stack right so it builds the
either the left-hand side or the
right-hand side the encoder or the
decoder and in passing the original data
I'm passing the layers I'm passing the
activations that I'd like to use and the
prefix so in the encoder I'm passing the
actual data right and to the decoder I'm
passing the encoder that is the symbol
that represents the encoded
representation in a bit more detail
you can think of build stack as
something like this just take a set of
layers enumerate through the layers
create the linear transform so the fully
connected layer if there's an activation
add the activation so simple
hopefully straightforward so for us that
meant this was our first reasonable pass
and we we did a little bit of work to
get there but it just meant that we had
two layers on one side two layers on the
other side 200 dimensions for our
embedded representation and I'm giving a
hint as to how I'm comparing things but
I'll go over that in a little bit
we also centralized of course all the
model creation into a class called
auto-encoder model but you can find well
you can find a ton of that on the web
anyways and there's there's a hint there
to the contexts things that I mentioned
earlier so when we did this simple bind
on the executor you could pass a context
and we had passed the CPU and that makes
that you can pass GPUs to your model for
the most part MX that will handle how to
distribute that data and into each
particular CPU though you and your
functions can also define how and when
to copy data from one GPU to another
which is quite useful so before I get
into this we're just defining how you
start defining that class of a model a
little a little discussion on MX net so
y MX that and not tensorflow or Kerris
so before MX that really meant that you
wanted to go a little bit more low-level
but you got speed benefits so I said I
still think beats the other frameworks
in the speed benchmark now there really
isn't a reason in my opinion not to
choose it because with their new gluon
api it is really very simple mechanic to
build to build networks having said that
I encourage you to use the symbolic API
because it really makes you think about
what you're building which is a
computation graph an explicit way and
you benefit from doing that so in this
case we're just defining the class
itself as the layers if we're going to a
dropout so we'll talk about that a
little bit the embedded dimension and
the context and build the encoder and
then build the decoder and the setup
itself we want to set up we want to bind
data to this model and to do it we have
this total set
function that just means we pass data
iterators and bind them and in
particular I'd like you to pay attention
to the net loss and net to group symbols
we'll go over them a little bit but
that's where you're defining the sort of
the terminal symbol or the terminal
symbols of your network so that's where
all the computation ends and that's from
where the gradient gets calculated
downward finally you just call a method
train in our class model and in
particular train will take your data set
iterate through it calculate that loss
and propagate the gradient downward and
that group simple that group symbol is
important because of some work that
we're going to do a little bit later on
that hopefully we'll get to in time so
how do you train it very simple API just
model dot fit
I've centralized that because there are
some other reasons in particular I'm
keeping layers metrics and optimization
parameters in the model I've taken them
out so that they fit in the slide we ran
it through our data and we had some
reasonable first results so what you're
looking at here is the original the
reconstructed and the embedded layer and
then you're also looking at the mean
results for cross-validation on that
data now you shouldn't be super
surprised all we're doing is recreating
data right so if you're recreating data
you should get reasonable results and
what we should be looking at is places
where we made mistakes so this at this
stage I haven't really talked about
which actual loss function is right
there's talking in general terms and in
particular if we were looking at
autoencoders if you had binary inputs
pretty traditional cross-entropy if you
had real valued inputs mean squared
error but what is a loss function in the
context of auto makoto encoding or an
auto encoder it's a similarity measure
right so you're essentially trying to
assess how similar the original input is
to your your output and so we because of
the nature of the data that we're
dealing with ended up using a cosine
distance right which is the one right at
the bottom and in particular I'd want us
to concentrate on these things so you're
not super clear but on the on the top
and on the left hand
site at the bottom there are places
where there's a mistake in the
reconstruction as we started looking at
what those mistakes were why did we make
those mistakes and we ended up finding
that the best way to find those mistakes
was to do not just a comparison of our
training set and the reconstructions but
actually of a transpose of both so if
you think about what imagine what a week
is right a week is a set of things that
you could have done and and whether you
did them or not right and counts so if
you take a transpose of those things
then it's all the things that could have
happened and the people who did them
write that transpose ended up being
super useful in figuring out how to
handle how to handle testing for foreign
for models another thing that should be
pretty clear from this is that the
embeddable presentation wasn't sparse at
all and we we have some intuition we
bring some priors about what we'd like
the embeddable presentation to look like
and so how did we solve these two things
well first we wanted to handle the
information loss as we were testing so
if we use the transpose for testing we
ended up realizing that maybe this feels
a little bit like cheating but why
aren't we using the transpose in the
loss itself but before we got there we
actually said well what if we add an
extra task to the learning that is about
finding the rarest thing that happened
in that week so what do I mean by that
you have a week's worth of activity some
of the things that happened were very
popular and one of the things that
happened was really rare so I can add an
extra task to the model to the training
procedure to try to predict the softmax
over it to try to predict that rarest
thing that should promote the underlying
representation to keep that information
so that was her first pass but her
second pass was wait why don't we simply
just add the transpose right we're both
trying to predict the weeks and the
whole domain and and an activity
structure and that ended up working
really well but it has an important
match size now becomes really important
right and it becomes really important
because batch size will determine how
many things end up being in that
transpose right how many unique things
end up being in the transpose
so the these were the modifications to
our loss and to handle that a better
representation we want to force the
representation to have a certain shape
right so one of the things that you do
when you're training of Anila neural
network a multi-layer perceptron and
you'd like to force the weights to be
small if you add a regularization term
right a traditional l2 regularization
for example what is the l2
regularization do so that forces those
individual weights to be smaller right
to have no one input no one particular
weight contribute a lot right it's
regularizing you can do exactly the same
with the better representation and the
shape that it should take so we're
adding a sparsity constraint we're
forcing the shape of H or DNR in this
notation right if the decoded
representation to hold a particular
shape that particular shape ends up
mattering a lot and so we had that
sparsity constraint we'll talk about it
a little bit so what does that mean we
now modify the model to sort of look
like this we've increased the original
dimensions increased the better
representation a little bit and added
that sparseness penalty that you can see
in the third to last line so that turns
our build stack method into this so we
say much before we enumerate through
layers we create a fully connected layer
and activation and now if we're at the
last part of the encoder we add a
sparsity penalty and Pemex that provides
a nice handy sparsity penalty but
essentially you could sort of a tour
with the sparsity penalty is by the the
transformation happens from the original
distribution of the embedded space into
the one that you're forcing and it's
right there at the bottom what results
that we get significantly improved
results in particularly keeping rare
information and also in how our
representations looked but there's a
there's a key thing that sort of matters
figuring out that we could add these
extra terms to the loss function to
promote characteristics in the embedded
representation and there being a key
thing because
you don't just have to you aren't just
allowed to add the terms to promote
keeping rare information you can now
promote other characteristics in that
embedded presentation and that's sort of
what we did we ended up saying okay well
if we have a specific set of attributes
that we'd like to model against we can
have beta and the white hat and our
prediction of the white hat be this
describe those things so for example if
I'd like to predict a segment for a
particular user I can make that since I
have that segment for that particular
user I can make that be a loss in might
know of my terms and that promotes that
a better position to then be useful for
modeling that particular characteristic
so segment for example if I go from 0 2
all the way to 2 that modeling step I
take the raw action data and I pass it
through this encoding step that gets a
smaller representation and that smaller
representation should allow you to
predict that segment so so far hopefully
this makes sense this isn't where we
stopped we're doing a ton of work the
part of the motivation around this work
was how do we get embeddings such that
we can start training sequence networks
networks that don't just understand bits
of activity but activity over time in
the relationship between one time unit
and another time unit and that's our
work that we were currently doing it's
essentially saying take that day level
or week level embedding and pass it
through something like a bio STM so that
you find a fixed size vector in
particular can I create a fixed size
vector that represents most of the
activity for a particular user if I am
able to do that that fixed size vector
should be quite useful in downstream
modeling tasks on the lower hand side we
have just the original sequence and on
the on the top you have the same
sequence reversed right so you're just
trying to predict the sequence itself
again so again it's another 1/4 of in
this case is an LST M auto encoder and
finally we'd like to be able to do
something slightly different this is
this is no longer about finding the size
representation but rather
to find a representation that has
certain characteristics in particular
that has a certain shape so applying
kale divergence to it so that we can
take that representation and corrupt it
and what during a corrupted add noise of
the distribution a noise of the type of
distribution that we chose to constrain
the representation by so that in the
corruption we can then use the datasets
characteristics without really using any
actual data from from people why would
we like to do that when we were doing
aggregate evaluation or aggregate
analysis we still like to distance
ourselves as much as we can from the
from the raw user data just for for
cleanliness sake all right and I've gone
I've gone quite fast actually and this
is a this is the the end of the taco
plate was useful and interesting thank
you
and if you have any questions feel free
to
yeah so the question was how do we
choose the architecture so we had a lot
of information to begin with because we
did a fair bit of work on the matrix
factorization tests so that told us
about roughly what kinds of sizes of the
embedding layer we needed so we had that
bit of information and then we started
with the simplest model that we could so
that's one layer a better representation
and the following layer right the
decoding layer it very it became very
quickly apparent that we wasn't over
overfitting was in a particular problem
so we increased depth fairly quickly
until we found that really were over
capacity there was no need to do it and
after that we started modifying how the
particularly activation functions affect
the final representation and that's
where we found most of the gain actually
and which activation functions with
which activation functions we ended up
using toward the end first number of
neurons in the center which we sort of
knew because of the initial tests that
we've done then number of layers
increasing almost almost by two by two
and by two then when we were clearly
over capacity stop adding new layers and
then after that testing on the
activation functions
it doesn't improve now yeah we did we
tried a bunch of different
pre-processing techniques both of the
matrix factorization step and afterwards
and it didn't give us any meaningful
improvement
[Music]
yeah absolutely so so we found four for
the loss that attaches the transpose the
the relationship between that factor and
the batch size was really important and
really what you're saying is you're
you're giving importance to how how much
you'd like to recreate the week itself
or the day itself or the full
information in a batch in a very large
batch which really means how much do I
want to understand each action type and
because the action types are quite quite
varied then we ended up going for the
final implementation of this promotes a
lot more learning the transpose than the
actual reconstruction does that make
sense it takes a couple days it doesn't
take a lot we do have I mean we're sort
of lucky that we have we have a lot of
data the main constraint there was GPU
memory so if we really wanted so there's
your bachelor's even if you're not doing
this kind of work matters right it
matters because you you the first time
you do this kind of work you try to go
for the largest batch sizes that fits in
your GPU because that's going to go the
fastest and then that's not necessarily
what you want in a way that's that was a
constraint for us we batch sizes that
were very large we're a necessity and
time wasn't really the constraint it was
how much of that batch size we could fit
into the GPUs so there's I there's a
significant amount of benefit to
creating to understanding their
characteristics of data set independent
of where that data set came from right
and this the simple said the simple
version of this or not the simple
version but the easy to intuit version
is images right so if you if you're
training a generative adversarial
Network half of that network is is a
variational auto encoder right you're
finding you're placing a constraint on
the embedding space so it has a certain
shape and then once you once you know it
has a certain shape you can just either
inject noise or create a sample from
noise from that distribution
then create an image if you do that in
the context of actual data right there
that comes from people people generate
data then you're you get a neat benefit
you keep the characteristics of that
data set while being able to really
distance yourself destroy delete all of
that original data as much as we can
relate to we're trying to find ways to
do that does that make sense you're
you're attempting to find mechanics that
give you the characteristics so that you
can in all of your training keep privacy
really because remember these encodings
are later used for downstream modeling
tasks great
thank you very much
[Applause]